can when i say shy what do you think of
uh a japanese school girl
[Music]
superpower it's a superpower kane oh oh
being shy is a superpower oh no
oh no what do you mean oh no
[Applause]
it's happening every everyone has
reacted to his videos i've never
actually seen a full one
so today's the day i'm ready i don't
know i don't know what maybe these are
[ __ ] great
all right who knows we're gonna find out
damn i'm super excited i already hate it
fine excited about today's video where
can i buy that shirt though oh
i can't imagine going up to someone
being like that sick shirt
yeah it's kind of like a i don't know
it's a very extrovert thing for an
introverted person to wear
yeah yeah it doesn't make any sense all
right
fine video because it's maybe there's a
message we don't know it yet
[Applause]
whoa oh yeah yo he's got the sick
face on the sleeve dart studio [ __ ]
oh my god whose face
there his face get it this collaboration
has been in the works through the
universe for such a long time 100
damn they had to work and pull the
strings to get this one
going huh i've been wanting to collab
with darman and here we are
and this video's this kind of a lot of
youtubers are collaborating with this
channel i mean they're
huge like 14 million views i get it but
also
why i'm really excited about it we're
also wearing the same
shirt in case you didn't notice it's
impossible to not notice this
shirt
i gotta get it i gotta get it we're
gonna be giving away
some brand new ps5s we've got
i've got two what are they dispersed and
so
are we ken bring out the ps5
i've got two digital versions and one
this version uh digital version now
no thank you nothing giving away to you
guys wait you bought the ps5s yeah
i i bought the ps5s too what i thought i
was gonna buy them
can you bring them in oh my god they had
no idea
they had no idea even though they were
right there these people were holding
them right beside the camera
i don't have a ps5 i've been looking for
one i can't follow these people
for like five of them you don't have a
ps5 no
god dammit based rain a rug whatever
[ __ ] rug his
name is rugged just hit me oh yeah
epic all right you got ps5's yeah now we
have five what should we do with them
okay well i guess we're just gonna give
away five bills
i'm down if you guys want to win a brand
new ps5 all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel
subscribe to facebook's channel and then
leave a comment
i can't believe people are still doing
[ __ ] giveaways
holy [ __ ] it's so annoying stop
this [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm so tired of it
[ __ ]
10 years of youtube people are still
like buying subs where they [ __ ]
it's so annoying
[Laughter]
it annoys me so much
done with your instagram and twitter or
email
so we can message you if you want should
we start today's video
let's do it baby all right here we go
ready let's do this let's go play should
we valley
he won't go he's always glued to that
thing
hey loser oh come with us what was that
sound oh a loser
you want to play real sports dude i've
heard that it's the opposite for kids
now
like if you're not playing fortnite and
you're a jock then you get bullied for
not playing
fortnite
oh no how do they turn tables
oh no well i mean it's just so much more
fun to play video games imagine like
having to be a jock and go to practice
that's effort
sweating like that
pressure from your parents oh my god i'm
still studying through that whole
football at that dude that
balls are heavy are they really really
that thing you think you got damaged hey
loser
oh come with us how do you think these
would be that funny this is
amazing
[Laughter]
oh man he's got like the jalapeno
flavored uh cheetos over here
lacrosse or whatever it's called that
flavor
actually what is wrong with this guy
he's looking like lacroix with this
straw
killing the environment we're gonna go
play a real sport
leave me alone brandon
hey get that back i'm gonna lose no
you're never gonna make anything of your
life if you just sit here doing this
all day that's not true my favorite
youtuber
face rug he makes a killing from lies
[Laughter]
listen you know this one guy he makes a
bunch of money from playing video games
i can do it too maybe you can maybe you
can or maybe you can go play football
these guys do
you know i feel like they're
appropriating my struggles here you know
what i mean
all right you know i mean huh i'm not
okay with this oh you can make money in
the game in a minute
all right yeah this doesn't happen
anymore this is so outdated
[ __ ] off she's got his own esports team
face clan
why my dreams like people know you can
make money on youtube now it's pretty
known fact like
back when i started nobody have any idea
there's like i guess i could make some
videos and
check and you're like oh i can't do this
well i guess i'm out of this [ __ ] one
day
let me get this straight your favorite
youtuber
is a rug
[Applause]
if you want to be a gamer you have to
make videos we've got a camera right
there
at least a rug would have more
personality
actual advice here like you want to be
you want to like do this for a living
well then you should actually
you know record it there's your camera
right there did he say that sorry i
missed that we've got a camera right
there
yeah ever even turned it on
uh no that's fair that's fair yeah
at least you gotta try
nervous but i'm going to one day
yeah right you're never going to you've
got to have the personality
and i hate to break it to you but you
have or you could use a giveaway so then
you know
it doesn't matter giveaways and collabs
you're just a shy dork so you'll never
be successful
i'm going to be successful you'll see
you haven't even started yet like come
on i'm good
get out of here i would sympathize with
him if he was trying at least but
he hasn't even started he's like i'm
gonna make it
what when i signed my first football
endorsement i'll be pulling up
in a porsche while you'll be waiting at
the bus stop like a loser
i told you you wasn't going to come
where you guys want to eat
there's three seats over there
seriously you're any lunch all by
yourself
well yeah i don't have any friends
that's because you're staring at a
screen all day i feel like that brother
is pretty reasonable
he says reasonable stuff but he takes it
too far every time you know
yeah he's being like a pro gamer right
he wants to be a pro gamer he's playing
he's practicing his games
[Music]
2000 iq [ __ ] look i got me that i got
some good advice for him
yeah you don't actually have to be good
at games to like make a living playing
games i mean
take us for example we're terrible right
now speak for yourself what the
hell where are we what the hell was that
have you seen my kd poster
day post your stats bro post your stats
post it show it
any game i beat you at minecraft got em
fortnite got em
minds uh tetris
pewdiepie friends that show that never
aired all right we gotta play that we
gotta play the video
wait what do you mean
[Laughter]
that was years ago ken are you ever
gonna let that go
okay listen i gotta tell the story okay
i'm gonna tell the story no
yeah i will not listen to this go ahead
we played
we played street fighter two where the
the whole show was on the couch we had
like old classic video games and it was
like a whole
whole big studio recording thing we
played street fighter 2.
i beat felix with one button all i did
was push medium kick the whole time
and perfect are you done blabbing yet
are you done
are you finished i'm playing the video
now i don't need this
i'm just shy okay
i'm too nervous to talk and you want to
be a youtuber
yeah that makes sense how many followers
does he have
that is an excellent question why don't
we find out
who did he check his snapchat
yeah that's what it looked like check
his snapchat
yeah he'd open his snapchat but then it
looks like instagram
i'm so confused favorite gamers nice
fuzz face
sick bizzle cyber whoa say
oh you have seven followers on instagram
and you want to be a youtuber you wanna
check mine out
check mine out i'm almost at a thousand
more hundred times what you got
that the quick match he's not just
strong he's also a big brain
damn man uh can i please have my tablet
back
you're right here's a tablet whoops
if you want this you're gonna have to
get it
from the trash no you're willing
you know
[Music]
why would he do that though that's just
kind of mean for no reason
i don't know he's giving me mixed vibes
here he's like the concerned older
brother guys like you know what you
actually need to do stuff if you're
going to be successful in this
but also i'm throwing your ticket how
about the trash
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's ruined now she's playing games
anymore
now get lost i don't want anyone
thinking we hang out with you
you came to sit with him yeah and he's
always his friends that go hey should we
like sit with your brother or hey what's
your brother doing
yo check it out there goes marie
dude you should ask her to be your
girlfriend yeah bro shoot your side
you know what watch this
watch it i'm so sorry i didn't see you
do you ever get off that thing yeah
when i shower and i get dressed i can't
believe
i got stuck with the biggest dork in the
world for my brother
you see that girl that's marie she's the
hottest girl in school
and i'm about to go ask her out okay so
don't you want a girlfriend it's so
cliche man
holy sh i didn't realize
like a after school special still like
guys like i'm about to go ask her out
and he's like okay so
it's a girl she has of a game don't you
understand
here bro what do you mean so
no girl is ever going to date a guy that
just plays video games all day
that's not true faze drug has a
girlfriend no way facebook that's a god
man
why i don't believe it i don't believe
hazrat has a girlfriend
i love the example it's so good even if
you are good at gaming you don't have
the personality for youtube
you're just too shy
but the thing is with youtube you can
either be really really good
and be successful or you can have a
great personality in big sustainable you
can be both from be successful you can
be nothing and be successful that's
what's created by youtube
yeah there's an audience for everyone
really
like all you gotta do is i'll play give
up
you're never gonna be successful you're
never gonna have any followers
and you're never gonna get any girls why
should he give up he hasn't even started
yet
no right like stop playing video games
the noise making you play
okay i'm so annoyed that you play all
the time
always just be a shy loser they must be
making this because
it responds to a lot of people right
yeah i mean yeah i was gonna say like
we're poking fun but i think like a lot
of kids like
do identify even though we're of the
opinion that things have changed and
like you know
mainly is the gamers these days but you
know bullying happens it sucks
it just well it's his brother come on
that is
yeah that i mean that's the weird family
dynamic they got going on here
come on they just see their dad if he's
acting like this [ __ ]
i'm gonna get me a girlfriend maybe you
should take some notes
why does he look like they're crying
over this hey marie
i tell you i'm getting a poor suit uh no
you didn't that's right oh god oh god
obviously this guy's already terrible
with money so you know should i get some
money i'm gonna buy a really expensive
car
yeah which is probably the worst what a
weird flex to say you're gonna buy a
porsche
i'm gonna buy a porsche girlfriend
brandon was right
i'm never gonna be successful i'm just
too shy to be like faze rug
i never should have even bought this
dumb merch
[Music]
another dumb merch underneath
[Laughter]
the reveal but you won oh yeah
oh what if he find his player too that'd
be so
sad hey are you okay no
hey hey are you okay i see you're taking
off a sweater
it's not even that high what's going on
over here bro yo bro yeah
you're taking my birthday check bro wait
why are you taking off my merch bro
what's going on here back going
on right now what the [ __ ] what's up
dumbass
i'm i'm sorry why are you having a bad
day it's my brother he thinks i'm a
loser because
oh my gosh face rug face ryan
why are you creeping around my high
school bro what are you doing yeah we
what are you
i thought yeah she
was awkward face drug doesn't know what
to do with his arms running
[ __ ] hey man you were saying your
brother thinks what
i still i still can't believe it's you
this is insane you're like the coolest
guy
ever thank you oh i'm sorry i'll calm
down my brother says i'm a loser because
because i'm shy and that i'll never make
it as a youtuber
he's probably right i should just listen
to him actually that's not true
you know how i know how uh-huh
because i'm also shy no way i didn't
stop you from thinking i'm cool right
what okay see i they're appropriating
my shyness i'm shy and i it's a [ __ ]
okay it's garbage it's not nothing it's
not a superpower
it's garbage shut up you are shy
no way that can't be possible yeah
actually a lot of the best youtubers are
no no
shut up you going too far face rug
you're done out of phase
he's bringing you into this
playstations 5 [ __ ] just think of being
shy as a super power
it doesn't make you a loser it makes you
cool how how
how explain elaborate
please tell me how it makes you cool how
well wow you seem like the the the
silent type you know you just you sit
there looking all mysterious dude i hate
those guys too holy [ __ ]
oh well that guy that never says
anything oh like i wonder what he's
thinking about he's just like
beep beep beep boop come on get out of
here i really like that
so you think i can make it as a youtuber
i don't think you can
i know you can oh yeah
[Laughter]
maybe one day you'll be a part of the
phase clan oh my gosh
that that would be my dream thanks phase
rug
i'm never gonna forget this and then
they kiss no all right
of course man good luck after meeting
his
idol ali got the inspiration he needed
to finally
start streaming oh no i forgot to get a
selfie
stick oh [ __ ] for a while building up
the courage to turn it on
and then he starts his very first stream
extremely awkward because he's streaming
on the playstation 5
yeah that ain't gonna fly dude that's
not what i don't work
hardly has any viewers
that's pretty good if you're just
starting up right i don't know what it's
usually like
you're watching your own stream you've
got a bot in there that's moderating
nobody and maybe like your friends
watching you
that's pretty much all you got oh yeah
i would not want to start streaming now
that seems like a nightmare
but then remember remember this is
remember
and decides to keep going i don't think
you can
as time goes on i don't think you can oh
he gets a little more comfortable being
on camera
more people start to find out about him
and
keep going up 3 000 eventually
he starts getting really popular
oh my god dude he's freaking me out
what's happening he's like
the first just
he gets so popular that he even gets
noticed but they come knocking on his
door hey bro contract
got it right here it's signing for the
contract to be
a part of the team will pay then we'll
pay him
what what the game yeah what's the
contract oh it's the underlying number
on the left down there
that's like three digits six
oh [ __ ] ali
couldn't be happy ali it seems like
you're doing fine on your own do not
sign with face claim
do not sign with anyone you're doing
fantastic
like the top 10
this is your chance to make it and then
one day
after school he happens to see his
brother
hey can you take your dad's car to the
mall no he's still mad about the last
time we used it
wait i thought you're buying a car from
your endorsement money
it hardly paid me anything 350 bucks
though that's sick bro
he sent a bad contract
oh look at this sick porsche
wow what that's a sick porsche wait is
that
this looks like a mom car yeah this was
like
the mini minivan just rolled up oh he's
got contact lenses now she
no way no way no what are you doing in
that car
oh hey guys wait it's not his brother
does he not know that he's making
hey guys we live in the same house and i
have like you know 5 000 people watching
me and i'm the talk of the school but
you know you don't know anything about
this yet
i just picked it up this morning you
like it
i don't understand school jesus how oh
well
i just signed a huge contract with faze
clan they even paid me an
advance of 100 grange so i went i went
ahead and spend it all
yeah i got this card depreciated as soon
as i pulled it off the lot so yeah
that's
a great idea but you know all i gotta do
is give them like 50 of my
income for an advance of 100 grand this
is great what does this deliver
this is also the thing i hear about the
cliche with youtube is like oh you make
money so
then it's cool it's not like they don't
show anything like how he's good or what
he's entertaining
or people like his videos it's just like
no look he he earned a car so
it's justified he you're a youtuber big
money
yeah it's all about money 100 he's
carrying that [ __ ] thing around
has he
oh also i got a big deal with g g fuse
watching this video
use code pewdiepie
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
it's the most legendary thing you can
achieve but no
[Music]
he well as long as they don't give him
his own flavor right
right don't give him his own flavor
please
the shy flavor
how did i know this have a million
followers
that's like more than 10 times the
amount of followers you have
dude the maps on these guys holy [ __ ]
these dudes are big friends
thanks brainiac hey actually
do you mind giving us a ride to the mall
so we don't have to take the bus
i would but i've actually got a date oh
[ __ ] did he cut
the hottest girl in school the same girl
she was bought by a [ __ ] car
listen this guy when he was shot no
prospect dumbest cliches
ever he's a big youtuber he's got money
he's got
cars he's got a girlfriend he has it all
it's the dream
i thought these videos were just like
harmless whatever
okay sure no not bullying great but they
project this image
that is so dumb and far from reality
that it's just like
what is this is this how like people
romanticize like youtubers yeah
i guess so [ __ ] this is why this is why
i'm so far out of everything because you
know i
i know actual youtubers and how
miserable
a lot of them they're romanticizing this
so
harsh dude like if you stream you have
to sweat your ass off being alive
constantly right now as hell
and if you look at my twitter and
everybody's like i've been streaming for
18 hours straight
stream see you tomorrow guys
and they made they just like i just he
just had the courage
shy so yeah let's go
but i was gonna buy a porsche i was
gonna get the girl
i don't understand me neither you're so
shy
how did you make it as a youtuber
well let me tell you i just realized
no oh oh being shy is a superpower
[Applause]
he's cringed out of his whole body right
there you see that his eyes just roll
back in his head like
guys i'm shy too subscribe
please it's a super power please if it's
a super power subscribe right now
we may give away a ps5 possibly maybe
probably not all the ps5s you could have
stuff in your house get it now if you
don't mind
i've got a date maybe you should take
some notes
take some notes i guess being shot
doesn't make you a loser
why so mad about actually makes you cool
it actually makes you really
sorry no bro i'm gonna
gonna beat him up i don't know i don't
know basic psychology okay
so i might be speaking out of line here
but is china's inherent in our genes
or is it something that you just like
develop well i think
most things in your personality are
things that get reinforced by like your
social surroundings i never heard of
shyness being encoded in your [ __ ]
dna so it just seems like there's
nothing wrong with being shy obviously
but i
also don't think it should be
highlighted as like you should be it's
it's great like you can work on he
worked out of his shyness
to make the videos right he was too shy
to do it
and then he started doing it it wasn't
like shyness helped him
i don't i mean i don't know me and mary
me and mary to the 24 and me you know
the blood test thingy and
it's like hey man you're like you know
britain and uh you're lactose intolerant
probably you're shy
but the thing that they could have
highlighted here is that online
anyone can make videos even if you are
shy it's not like
it helped him in any way it's rather
finding a different vehicle
right well you know most of most of
everybody that not everybody you know
but a lot of people you know that do
this we're all introverted people
and the comfort you just sit in your
room with just your camera and then
you you basically practice not being shy
and seem like you're not
person eventually you know now we can
get in front of a stage and talk to
people you know it's not even a big deal
anymore right
watch my first videos and see how shy
and awkward they are
like that's some cringe yeah
hey a little too harsh today huh
just saying all right maybe maybe just
thinking about my own
whatever let's go before we miss the bus
hey dartmouth [ __ ] this video i didn't
think it would annoy me so much
keep changing lives how this is like the
lottery of youtube content right you're
selling people a dream that doesn't
exist
to me at least i obviously want to exist
but yeah
small very yeah i want other people to
definitely
know they had the chance to be naked but
like this is so out of that in my
opinion this is like
exists in his own bubble of weirdest
yeah i hate this video i hated it well
it's like the
the the dream that they're going for
here like him making it like that is
literally like the top like very small
percentage of people that do this
like there's millions of channels and
very few of them get to the level that
we are at you know even less so you so
it's like
sure maybe you can make some money and
doing this maybe you can quit your job
but i don't know if you could be going
flexing your porsche or anything like
that but it's also like they they showed
it like
a porsche was the reason he did it or to
get a girl or something
they never showed like his community
that he built her
yeah yeah that actually
affects you daily yeah dumb i hate it
he got money he got the car he got the
girl big youtuber face rug baby
yeah subscribe being shy as a super
power the end
well that was uh some good cringe thank
you yeah
i'm cringing i i kind of feel bad
because i i went in with this
trying to be like yeah they're fine but
no i hated it if you're shy
smash like
that's it all right
[Laughter]
caught you you're using internet without
a vpn
cringe oh look at this dude
sign up with nordvpn today and stop
being crazy
for those who don't know a vpn it helps
you browse the internet safely
but most importantly freely get past
annoying country restrictions
i can definitely say that so many times
you try and watch a show and it's like
ah
can't watch it there i got you every
time it's like yeah no problem there's
no vpn i already have the subscription
it's all done i don't have to think
about it it's one of those things that's
really just
it's just good to have i recommend it if
you sign up for a two-year plan with
nordvpn
you get a huge discount plus a one-month
additional for free
so if you take that offer it's really
good you sign up using the code
pewdiepie
that's how you get epic access to it
you're welcome
if that wasn't good enough for you and
you're not sure if a vpn is
really worth it or not for you you can
try it risk free
for 30 days with a money back guarantee
nordvpn doesn't compromise on speed it's
super fast i use it all the time i can't
tell the difference if i'm using it or
not
there's absolutely no data logging
whatsoever
so be safe out there gamers use nordvpn
i recommend it that's nordvpn.com
pewdiepie link in description thank you
for sponsoring this video